love when this man comes on the show
love his area 21 on NBA on TNT s weekly
coverage and he's going to host it
during TNT's coverage of the NBA
Playoffs on Tuesdays he is Kevin Garnett
how are you kg not better for talking to
you better for talk are you on Twitter
now personally did I notice that or have
you been on before they are uh you know
my team is telling me that you know now
I'm not real active on social manner
people get mad cuz our only post a bunch
of stuff but um I like my motto in life
is that I'm living will tell much if
you'd stop into you know like I get it I
guess sometimes if I'm saying something
amazing yeah I'll share but I'm minute
man you know I don't think so let me get
a video or this in there I don't I don't
think like that but yeah I'm trying to
push my social to another level but no
no not just yet not just yet
how how would it have been different for
you if there was social media Twitter
Instagram Facebook when you were playing
oh man changed everything because what
it is it gives access you know to have
access to me or vice versa or me have
access to the world and then be able to
voice my pain at any time that would
have been very powerful very powerful I
don't think they were staring with a
really likes day you'd have been a
little lighter in the wallet
you think on occasion you know why it
was so new and I think that you know you
have so many constitutional First
Amendment's and Moreno being able to
speak and you know I think we were to
challenge that major league you can't
muzzle or you know script someone to do
something obviously within the
guidelines of where you working at in
your workplace yeah but we should come
out of that you're a person in the human
and you know I think that that Kim has a
receding nice Rasheed stack I like just
so I can you imagine all of us on social
media me that would have been a riot man
what yeah I know
and and that's the interesting thing
about LeBron Kevin that you hear quite a
bit is that he is in terms of at the NBA
an NBA goat right the one who has gone
through his entire career almost start
to finish with the social media presence
and
more people learning more about him and
obviously the two-way street they could
let him know what they think about him
and that that makes what he's done more
impressive what are your thoughts on
that notion well I think that in every
era is going to be boost I think when
dr. J played Michael Jordan coming into
his own and the fact that magic and
Larry was kind of in like a mid peak
form to be able to pass it on to Isiah I
there - Michael Michael took it and and
in made our sport global and I think
that when you put on a you know NASA
another type of error you know Kobe
Bryant you know could be considered than
our our our our generation - Michael
Jordan after Michael with you know to
take it and and and put it into 81 and
show another form of scoring another
form of of the 23 or the form of that
right you look at LeBron and he caught
social media right when he's kind of
like in the middle right where well
Michael was when the league was coming
off for so many stigmas of drug abuse
and now working hard and you know God's
been in shape and blah blah blah Michael
took it and blossomed it I see the Bron
doing the same thing you know he took
he's taking the advantage of
understanding social media very early on
with not only that but information and
the Italian data you tie your knowing
how to move and and take content and put
it on and for how long and how all the
guy nasus they're going to social he's
mastered it because he's been in a mess
to where he's like a fraternity he's
taking his licks
he's been proven he's proven he's
probably the only great others in the
laneway in our game pau gasol can go
into that conversation I would say maybe
maybe Dwight Howard just because of the
accolades but that's very few but when
you see what he's done with social media
and how he's made it work for now
lowering his businesses is multiple
businesses been able to promote being
able to speak back been able to you know
hear from him versus an outlet versus a
source versus a reporter you know
putting words in your mouth or speaking
for you this is what I like about social
media being able to get it straight from
the ass
straight from the person here verbatim
now what are you giving them what are
you stimulated what are you teaching
what are you giving to the world and I
think that what he's putting out as his
brand has been beautiful and it's been
very very calculated
you know LeBron is probably considered a
great and not just being on the floor
but in the community also his business
is successful like the doomed brand his
Bret he's done a great job at the social
aspect of forming his brand he's one and
only cagey the host of area 21 on TNT
which is going to air over 40 playoff
games beginning Sunday an exclusive
coverage of the Western Conference
Finals which any people think is the de
facto AAA NBA Finals Kevin Garnett here
on the Rich Eisen show all right let's
get into it here what what harden is
done with Houston he is the most
valuable player on the team with the
most wins and then you look at just the
sheer numbers and LeBron what he's doing
at his age is something we've never
really seen who's the MVP of 2017-18
Kevin I think every year we condemn
their give it to LeBron every year right
and I think that we will all get tired
of doing that right but you know lb is
what he lb is lb he is what he is - this
year and I think James Harden has been
very consistent in being it's either
runner up or considered the contender
for he's been very consistent with that
I think the last 3-4 years he's been in
these talks he's been in the race he's
been neither - Russell had an
unbelievable year last year very magical
and it was no hands down everybody
understood that but this year is James
Hart he's been very consistent with but
with what you consider a MVP to be not
only that useless playing defense is
playing defense they all have they have
Crick they have became more scrappier
than a lot of these teams you know it
was the finesse team they look scrappy
mutia definitely brought a presence to
that team they they have a I love their
team I'm just I just want to see stamina
wise cambiar keep it up man you know
when you start getting to the higher
ground
you know you know Timmy's and now you're
going to accomplish finals those a
really testy very very very very very
high intensity moments mended it but I
just I don't know now I'm ready to see
James take his game to another level and
I'm but he's the MVP of this season 2018
and then in terms of Rookie of the Year
Donovan Mitchell became the first player
first rookie since Carmelo to lead his
team in points and the team making the
playoffs I would have handed it to him
certainly midway through the season
certainly when he won the slam dunk
contest here in Los Angeles but now here
come the Sixers who are one win against
24 win Atlanta a way of tying the record
for most consecutive wins to close out a
season and man what Ben Simmons is doing
during this run triple doubling during
this 14 game win streak
who's the Rookie of the Year oh my god
Norma conspiracy theorist right okay I
mean look at her like you know we're
super tight at the point in the
environment to start doing all this
other stuff and just started really
separating himself again I don't know
the gods upstairs say you know what
let's not Joelle and beat out of these
last couple games to show Big Ben
Simmons greatness and it just it's
almost like Joe Joe Kennedy playing with
the Nasdaq again in fixing a loser so
that anybody else can do you know like
it that whole theory of all of this but
that's what's just happening that just
would happen and Ben Simmons stock has
went through the roof these last I think
seven eight games he's been off the
charts but I don't know if he's still
playing their way if Joelle is playing
I'm I love this I love Philly I love
what they're doing they're definitely
the right direction and I'll go ahead it
in the right direction but for me man
this is a toss-up but I don't think you
can go wrong with either one I think
when you gave whether it's for the Grant
Hill and Jason Kidd they had that so
Cohen Cola
MVP Zork over key of the years yep I see
this that's the same thing Ben Simmons
regardless had a year in the league and
people don't like to really talk about
it that's a influence or that waivers or
whatever
you still have to play I get that but
that helps and you know what to
anticipate to come in brand-new coming
to a franchise that has no uncertainties
of the future don't know what's going on
X's and Y's barrels veritable's falling
all over the place they just lost their
best player and this kid came in took
that just willingly I did not see this
coming from I'll watch I'll watch
basketball you know I saw him in college
he didn't stand out to be something over
the top he's taking his game to the next
level he is on another level of playing
basketball confidence wise and for that
man I got I got a salute Donovan maez
man that's that's tough to come into as
a rookie but those type of intentions
and in Kiwanis come on man that's that's
amazing so what he's doing was very you
know he has a very good team too Gobert
has a very very good team I like his
team I like Utah things do not want to
see them in the playoffs they're gonna
be a menace and I think they gonna make
some noise but if I had to pick ma'am I
love Ben Simmons but I gotta go with
Donovan Mitchell but I wouldn't be mad
if they did a dual Rookie of the Year
understand a few more minutes left with
Kevin Garnett 15 time NBA all-star NBA
champion of the NBA MVP host of area 21
here in the Rich Eisen show so are you
not buying Philadelphia is a real deep
threat in the Eastern Conference or are
you definitely I say that okay
I'm definitely buying some stock in the
process I'm trusting in it like
everybody else in Philly I'm just
sitting back waiting to see how it all
cook up well like what about being
LeBron if they face LeBron with Joelle
back healthy a lot that's a lot you know
you got a you got a bill you a game with
you when you re trying to dethrone
somebody you trying to take somebody off
a spider you trying to be somebody I
wanted to know and ask the question you
risk do you think that we as fans are
tired of the narrative of LeBron going
to the finals every year
you think the league is a bit tired of
that you think that that's starting to
be a bit weather I think what the league
is kind of tired of is nobody really
being a threat to Golden State I think
that's what it is I don't have LeBron
fatigue I love watching him play I love
watching him challenge
I love watching him take it all on I
love how he steps I mean how few people
in our day and age Kevin yours and mine
does anybody step on a stage with all
the expectation and exceeded right not
many people can do that he's one of them
I want to see Golden State be taken to
seven games that's what I want to see I
don't I don't know who's gonna do maybe
it's Houston maybe it is gonna be on TNT
and the Western Conference Finals I
don't know that's the lateen
nothing's forgiving I'm gonna tell you
that right now nothing is given I don't
think there's a lot of teams playing a
really good basketball right now
Portland's playing really good Utah's
playing really like this there's some
teams that you don't necessarily world
run up wall right now go to stating
isn't does it look super polished you
know they look they look good the other
night and spins y'all saw that but it up
man I'm sitting there watching it all
and I got a little spectacles I'm
watching it up close like I'm here see
nothing you understand I'm man i watch
it at all I don't know man some we gonna
have some surprises this year well all I
know is that again and just I guess to
bring this whole thing full circle with
the playoff starting now now that after
the whole long season of will they or
won't they and how good are they
Oklahoma City New Orleans and San
Antonio all punched their ticket last
night and they're now in right now it's
a fresh season which one of those do you
think is the most dangerous OKC by far
OKC goes in there and the button is hit
and they just Oh wad up they can upset a
lot of people and you can't ever count
out pop-up has been here with less he's
been here he's went further with less
mm-hm and it's about team with him this
is where he's he's great at this he's
great at the playoffs he understands
matchups he understands seedings so you
always gotta watch pop but no one wants
to see OKC right now because of the
talent alone can they do it though yeah
I know and it looks like if everything
stays the same they might be the first
one to draw a Golden State
[Music]
Keiji I love our chats and love area 21
and I look forward already to our next
one during the playoffs which is always
real man thanks always have me on and
you know literally hold something right
watching right back at you Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience